this program is brought to you by Emory
University
I'm the principal investigator here on a
national clinical trial funded by the
federal government called iCare iCare
stands for interdisciplinary
comprehensive arm rehabilitation
evaluation contained within this study
is our exploration of a new technique
that's based upon the best evidence for
a rehabilitation potential of the arm
and hand among folks who had a stroke
within the past three months and who
have some capability of initiating or
starting movement at their elbow wrist
and fingers as though they're beginning
to reach towards an object the signature
piece of this intervention is called
ASAP accelerated skill acquisition
program and what that means is that we
take the best evidence that exists which
includes constraining the better limb a
technique that was studied here at Emory
quite extensively over the past several
years strengthening of the upper
extremity various forms of repetitive
task practice and providing challenges
to patients to improve their movement
and functional capability what makes us
a little bit different from typical
therapy is that unlike therapies in
which the occupational or physical
therapist tells the patient what to do
much of what is done in this
intervention is determined by the
patient through a series of explorations
we call power of the self-efficacy what
that means is the patient helped decide
themselves what is successful and not
successful as they try to complete the
task the therapist is there to encourage
the patient let's assume that an
activity that's valued important to the
patient is their ability to reach for
open and retrieve pills from their
toolbox the training might include the
challenges of being able to reach
towards a pillbox extend their open the
arm raise the fingers open to grasp that
and then bring it towards the individual
if we wish them to be able to use their
in paradigm or transfer the pillbox to
the better hand and then work on being
able to twist and open the box retrieve
it and move it and then gently put it
down and begin to turn the box so that
either pills can be dropped into the
hand or the fingers can showing the
finite movement to be able to retrieve
individual pills from the box and then
lay them down so this activity would be
a sequence of training that would
challenge the patient to more
progressively work harder greater
complexity to achieve this independent
goal the reason we do this is simply to
improve patient's ability to
problem-solve and develop that behavior
so that it will be retained and used
throughout the remainder of the
patient's rehabilitation
once they have left this procedure
you
the preceding program is copyrighted by
Emory University